GOOD MORNING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MARCH
TWENTY EIGHTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER -- PLEASE ADVISE AND
AUDIO VIDEO RECORDED TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS REMAIN IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED A MAN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HERE
FLORA GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK
SILVA HERE RAMOS THREE THIS
YEAR WICKS HERE WE HAVE A
CORPSMAN WE HAVE CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION SENATE MISS
CARILLO MR MATHIS -- ASPECT
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
-- BY COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA
AYE FLORA AYE GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA FIRST OF ALL
I RAMOS RAMOS I RIVERSIDE
REINVEST I WAKE SIGN WICKS I
AM INTERESTED AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE OKAY THE MOTIONS PASS
AND THIS RULES GLAZER TURNED